[Musique]
large n'est pas dangereux large est un
un phénomène naturel qui se développe
pendant les mois de printemps et d'été dans
latitudes moyennes mais aussi aux pôles tout
ce qui assombrit la neige la cause
la fusion parce qu'elle l'accélère
l'absorption du rayonnement
[Musique]
dans cet endroit, nous n'essayons pas de
quantifier l'effet d'autres phénomènes
qui s'ajoutent au direct
d'impact humain qui sont de caractère
plus naturel mais ils peuvent avoir en
un certain mode de relations avec
présence par exemple de l'homme à ces
altitude via les remontées mécaniques e
randonnée
[Musique]
qui a un problème il nous manque ça
algues qui nous aident malheureusement nous sommes
causant des dommages irréversibles et nous sommes
Je suis déjà au bord du non-retour je pense
[Musique]